[Music]
good morning John it's Friday June 15th
really sorry about this but at least I
have the divine light of God John coming
to see you is probably worth this but
only just
I hate flying on airplanes and living in
Montana doesn't make us any easier I
woke up at around 6 o'clock in the
morning to get in a cab this morning and
I will arrive home at one o'clock in the
morning dominican rough road time what I
want to be doing right now isn't
sleeping but instead I'm sitting at the
base of a column of light with people
staring at me because they obviously
think that I'm really
but I'm just gonna do it because my
plane will arrive in Missoula after the
deadline and I must continue the
Brotherhood
so that's enough complaining then I
think we're starting to realize that
there might be long spaces of time
between when we get to see each other
while that I guess is normal in this day
and age it's not comfortable and it
sucks especially when there's an evil
baby orphanage to create to be excited
to hear that John and I were able to
work on the evil baby orphanage a while
on our family vacation and I can tell
you one thing for sure the idea is not
getting any less awesome but of course
being able to discuss the evil baby
orphanage was only one of the many
benefits of having some non-textual but
also non videoblog communication going
on between the brothers brotherhood 2.0
mate became a little bit redundant for
that week but it helped highlight the
difference between textual communication
and videoblog communication and
face-to-face communication and that kind
of stuff is really I guess what this
project is about what I realize is
neither of us are really quite ourselves
over instant messenger or even over the
video blogs but we can't not be
ourselves face-to-face and it helped
remind me what kind of guy you really
are and also how totally crazy you can
be sometimes I mean I was excited about
the idea of donkey polo mostly just
because I think it's absolutely
ridiculous but I can't say I understand
your supreme disappointment I think that
heat is a fine reason to cancel
miniature donkey polo
can you think of anything more sad than
a miniature donkey overheating that
would be horrible but aside from your
occasional bouts of high stress insanity
you're pretty amazing brother and a
pretty amazing guy and I'm really happy
to be your brother I hope you're having
a good time your last day in the dr i
wish i was still there with you a lot
except that i really
want to be home right now more than
anything else in the fluid
Catherine is actually going to see this
video before she sees me which is a
little bit strange I love you baby
I'll see you soon and John I will see
you